so either way the man pulls me out we're
good to go
i'm glad he didn't ask me to come over
anything like that that'd be weird but
either way
king or sting it helping people on the
side of the road
would you stop or wouldn't you stop gang
gang was the entire audience going to or
coming back from rehab
back off my broccolini get your life
together
yeah we're close we live we live in that
area we both got out of the chaos and
moved out to the
it was time to move out to an area where
the riots were more of a
televised event than the spectator event
yeah they were live when i lived in west
hollywood they were live it was like oh
i'm going out to a live event
then i moved out to where i live now
it's like oh this is over zoom yes
it's like we're skyping into the
nightmare yeah yeah
but if you talk to roguini x like it was
live for him all the time like dude yeah
you live by us
he i know that guy i love him to death
but it's just so funny because it's like
he
like the idea that he was like a social
butterfly is insane you know he's like i
can't go out anywhere it's like what
no he's like bigfoot he lived in like a
cave with mountain lions yeah
no one got close to if they had those
guys were drunk he lived yeah it was
like
he lived in the back head he's like i'm
just sick of this the homeless i'm like
dude
i haven't seen a homeless guy in years
yeah
yeah yeah no there's not that many
homeless where we're at
no there's no few homeless horses yeah
it's a couple of bobcats bobcats but uh
maybe buy a tiger from whitney
yeah yeah but it's not it's not that bad
but i like it it's quiet i've never
lived out in a natural area that has
more nature in this area especially
come from new york new york had no
nature we had rats and
stuff like that but now we i see horses
i see like uh every now and then a lot
of hawks and eagles
yeah hell yeah it's beautiful it's nice
um are you
because though kind of the whole crew
just kind of
just yeah took off yeah were you
were you i mean you and i have talked
about this off here but were you
close to moving while like kind of
everybody else i wasn't close to it but
i'm
i was thinking about it i never i'd
never say never
i think that you look at the money you
spend in l.a it's a lot of money
uh do what you save money the problem is
what am i gonna do am i gonna live in a
cul-de-sac in texas i have like a
neighbor with big hair and then she
comes over and we're just smoking like
lucky strikes in the backyard and just
hanging
like what are we gonna do that's my
question i'm like what's gonna
happen yeah if i move down there it's
just gonna be
quiet kind of depressing like if someone
about la it's fun it's ridiculous but
it's fun
it's fun we'll talk to theo he moved to
nashville what do you do yes
nothing that's the problems nothing yeah
there's no i'm lonely as [ __ ] i'm like
yeah
yeah dude you're probably going to
follow whatever city you move to i like
la i like going out to
dinner and seeing these crazy people
that are you know 15 year old
billionaires and like craziness and
youtubers and lamborghini youtubers and
lamborghini people just walking around
in like a lime green onesie yeah
you know i mean just that whole it's
crazy but
to me it's it's as a comedian there's
more to make fun of here
there's more to make fun of him there's
more there's more energy here and then
also
what's interesting is if and i didn't
know this maybe you do because your
family's still back in new york we had
schultz on a few weeks ago
he gets he goes dude this is terrible
here you don't realize how bad we have
it here
till you get out right he's like just
like north korea you guys can't do [ __ ]
he's like what can i eat i'm like
nowhere
it's bad postmates it here i go you're
from new york dude you guys
you guys are just the same as this
because no we're not no they're not
there's the newspaper
they're gonna they'll be there they're
gonna get yeah they're gonna get there
they should just shut it down again
because these hospitals are supposedly
all [ __ ] up and then
you know they're just gonna shut it down
and shut down the schools they'll shut
it down again
i mean what are you gonna do i mean
listen i don't know i just i'm at a
certain point now where i go like
i don't even watch the news anymore
because it's like i just feel like it's
on loop
so i'm like all right shut it down or
open it up or
just let me know when i can go to
[ __ ] panera
let me know when i can sit in a panera
yeah let me know when you're all good
let me know when i could have a like a
french onion soup at panera yeah
and then that's okay but as far as
everything else like i don't even care
i just try to be funny and and stay away
from it uh because you start to lose
your mind
and you're like [ __ ] i just hope that
like whether it's the vaccine whatever
works i just hope by the spring
by the spring summer we're like getting
out of it it will i hope yeah
do you see are you into the vaccine will
you take it yeah i'll take it i
listen i will do whatever it takes i
agree with you
i'd like to take it in a little while
like not immediately no i don't be like
it's like buying a tesla let everybody
get it yeah let the team you don't want
the first edition tesla let nurses get
it
and then i'll i'll try it later after
two or three hundred million people have
gone
they're saying that uh that uh
like the the first people that get it
like there's no like crazy side effects
but also if eventually if you want to
travel you're going to have to have you
have to have it for our jobs we're going
to have to have it we go all over the
country then all over the world we're
going to need to have it we're not going
to have an option
you know i just hope it works yeah i'm
just going to hold back a little bit the
whole thing is like let's hope it
[ __ ] works yeah
again it's like tesla if you bought that
first dish in tesla those things were
running into the walls
yeah yeah now they're great now they're
great yeah
all right nick what do you got doug
robert kennedy jr said
the vaccine uh it'll it'll cure you but
it won't stop you from spreading
it which a lot of people think like so
but if it cures everybody if they kill
everybody if they need to vaccinate
everything the problem with that type of
vaccine is
everybody's got to have it for it to
work right and there's been so much like
[ __ ] on the vaccine that now everyone
doesn't know
nobody's like now they're talking about
the first responders like yeah we're
good nobody's excited about it nobody's
like yo
no just nobody's calling it yo bro just
my dad the [ __ ] vaccine is out
i can't wait let's go it's like a ps5 so
like let's do it let's do this
let's go you're definitely into it
that's good
i'll tell you who's doing it right it's
trump and marlo mar-a-lago
yeah you say it have you been down there
i've never been down there
in the area you get why he was like the
white house is a dump
and he's oh it's just [ __ ] chills and
you have floors it's gorgeous dude
we went down the beach is amazing it's
it's slow but it's amazing
it's slow but he's 75 and you know dude
you should see his compound there
it's amazing of course like yeah of
course [ __ ] the white house of course
that's why he's down there yeah
he loves you i love florida man i think
that might be the retirement score
yeah it's either there it's really only
florida or arizona
florida is amazing scottsdale arizona is
nice too
hell yeah but florida's just i like the
ocean
i like looking out at the water you guys
both sherlocks crack the code retire in
arizona or florida it's like
that's that's why people have been doing
it yeah
yeah you're right i know he's making fun
of us but yeah i know but yeah
trying to pick the energy up a little
roasting
i mean yeah we're do we're doing the
thing that other people have done
successfully and enjoyed yeah
let me see what this kid's talking about
yeah not in florida get in some debate
club
evidently a fan of you too he knew what
you're up to this weekend
hey guys it's nick from bum [ __ ]
tennessee
got a debate club for you heard you guys
were having on tim dillon
and then his little war he's got going
on with airbnb correct
so the debate you stick with those
airbnbs with those
nice clean hit us or you go to those
motel sixes where all them lot
uh that have an airbnb and joshua tree
who raided me poorly
breaking a cactus how do i even do that
you sloppy [ __ ] talking about
you goofy [ __ ] how do i even break a
[ __ ] cactus okay
the the the literal furniture was like
art pieces no one could sit in it
they were like [ __ ] chairs without
backs how long were you there
one night one night i brought a few
friends out there got a good deal on it
got it for less than a half of what it
usually rents for because
last minute oh gotcha because we're just
out in palm springs it's too cold i'm
like let's all go to joshua tree
and uh we went out there i had my
producer with me i had
another guy who podcast with me and then
i think if you go on my story you might
be able to still see these [ __ ]
chairs that they had
it was like to a point so like how did
just to for their defense
how uh how did the cactus get broke
no one touched it this is the thing the
cactus was like falling apart yeah i
probably don't have it on my side yeah
i don't have it but the reality is these
chairs were like literally
so like have you ever seen chairs where
you're like no one can sit on them those
weren't them
no one can sit on these [ __ ] chairs
and
uh i have one here i have i have a photo
of one here i'll just i'll just give it
to you right now
but just to give you an idea of how bad
it was so did they tell you nothing
oh you don't want to sit on them they
look horrible look at that oh they're
terrible
so i mean this this [ __ ] [ __ ] like
wrote this whole thing where she was
like
he was a bad guest he clogged the
toilets he broke our chairs nobody broke
anything
the chairs were like the chairs were
like weird chairs that you like
we went up to them they were like
falling apart like you put them together
and we just left a few dishes in the
sink and that was it did you have a
rager though
no we did four people just had a dinner
nobody had a rager
so i threatened uh her on her text
i said um well now i know where where
your house is now hopefully nothing
happens to it that's what you
said yeah she said i was stupid and then
she goes are you threatening me i'm like
lol we'll see what happens
and then i sent her a gift of the
simpsons house burning you know the
citizen's house
that burns that gift i sent that to her
and she's like okay bro
and then i just trashed her on my
podcast because she's being a [ __ ]
and her and her wife are horrible people
is she older her name's like
mila chona and mila yeah they have these
dumb like they're posing with a dog in
their airbnb photo whatever they're like
we worked our whole lives in this house
like
shut the [ __ ] up shut up so and i gave
them a great review because i'm not a
rat and i don't hurt people's business
so i was like a beautiful place
i never you know give somebody a bad
review never
i don't yelp i don't comment uber i
don't know uber no
i don't do any of that i have spit on an
uber driver
we've gotten a physical fight where i
kicked the back of his chair
and he he spit at me and i spit back at
him because he wouldn't take me through
the drive through taco bell
i still rated him highly you understand
i still rated him
because up until our fight he did fine
yeah he's cool he did a good job he cut
through traffic you're trying to get a
job where are you trying to get a double
decker are you trying to get a
a cheesy gordita crunch oh yeah i said
let's just go through the drive-through
and he said no
and he started screaming at me so i just
started kicking his seat like kick in
the back of a seat
then he spit on me i spit on him and
then i had to get out of the car
but uber uber kicked me off for like six
months but now i'm back
i'm back and that's cool and the
opposite happened i was
i drove for uber and i this lesbian
couple was in the back and it was bar
time and this was back in the day when
surge was huge it'd be five times ten
times
yeah make two two hundred dollars one
ride and they asked to go through an in
and out drive-through
and i was like no i'm sorry i can't do
that and they got super pissed and
they're like drop us off here
and they smashed my window and they
stole all the waters on my back of my
car
oh but here's the deal man why are you
not
making them happy uh because time is
time is money at that point get out of
my car it's an equal transaction like
i don't i'm an independent contractor
did you not like
did you not want to get a [ __ ] double
double animal stuff
[ __ ] small bro not a half hour later
i didn't oh wow dude
you're gonna get money right because the
lesbians and some spread that could have
been a [ __ ] real story
there's two ways to really make money on
uber it's distance traveled and number
of rides
sitting idle you're not going to make
your money wow understood
hey didn't know that did they leave you
a bad review oh yeah but i i called uber
immediately because i knew it was going
to be an issue
and so like you got to get out right now
i don't need bad reviews so listen this
year
like i had a bad airbnb in uh palm beach
my brother booked it it was a real
[ __ ] job the pictures look dope dude
so airbnb [ __ ]
literally texted me this morning
threatening yuno would you like me to
see if i can get that review removed
and i wrote yes so i think it worked the
roast
was big and i think people went to her
and said this guy's having a lot of fun
with your house
he's making a mockery of it as it
deserves to be made a mockery
it's not gonna cause it is ridiculous
and it's not no it will not stop i will
have
fans of mine rent the airbnb and i will
go in it and just go
crazy and be like [ __ ] i'll never leave
your home
i'll live in your [ __ ] house you're
gonna squat i'll squat there i'll do
whatever and she got mad because we made
like burgers and like baked beans and
like other campfire foods
yeah they sound like real [ __ ] don't
get mad at me i left i left a few dishes
in the sink she's like the cleaning crew
complained i'm like about what cleaning
yes that's her [ __ ] i paid a 400
cleaning fee [ __ ]
do it yeah we we never leave but here's
here's what i would say i love airbnbs i
will still go probably airbnb over
hotels in most situations
hey because like when i was on the road
to a comedy i brought my opener with me
and when we were it's an air
if i get a hotel i want a nice hotel so
if i gotta get him a room in the mia
room
it's a lot of money tonight right now we
don't get a yard we don't get this we
don't get that
with an airbnb we each have our own room
we have rooms to spare and sometimes we
have a pool we have a yard
we have a more comforting area yeah it's
much more comfortable man
all day i don't do hotels at all anymore
especially during covet i mean but i'll
go to like the rich carlton in naples
there's certain hotels i like sure
certain hotels i like
blueberry pancakes on a beach holler on
the beach
i would still rather do airbnb even over
a nice hotel because you can get a dope
you should see the difference is this is
the one difference and now because a
covered hotel is the one difference that
hotels are not bringing to the table
right now and it is like a room service
so it's like there's something nice
about being like hey i'm i i'm in a
hotel i walk right to the beach i sit on
my chair
where's my drinks where's my food that's
the reality that's the only thing i
don't even drink but like
just you know even to just be like hey
man i'm [ __ ] hot can you get me a
bottle of water can you give me
something
get me a mozzarella stick and they do it
and you tip
them and that's a nice transaction but
for sure not [ __ ] a motel
6 over airbnb no that young man was
asking no that young man is figuring out
what is the best place to do math with
his mother
yeah because like i like to like like
crystal with my parents where can we do
that and it's like i don't know dude
no good decisions have come out of motel
6 100 i used to do cocaine in motels
never a motel six not that bad
but uh and and uh they were fun rooms to
just because you had wind protection are
you completely
uh sober now 100 no drinks 10 years
oh wow wow no no uh temptation at all
no i mean can you be around it
occasionally the one thing that i do is
like i have occasional slip up like
occasionally i'll do heroin
i'll show like i shoot heroin i'll shoot
up but that's it no
okay occasionally i'll have a cigarette
that's the baddest thing i do that's not
bad it's not great
are you tempted though like when you go
to a comedy club there's alcohol
everywhere
never because i'm over it it's you're
tempted for the first two or three years
then you're over and i'm like i'm just
over it
yeah yeah that makes sense so airbnb it
is
playoffs playoffs you want to talk about
playoffs yeah that's right football's
playoff
is starting this weekend we're talking
wild cards and guess what
you want to make bank while you're
watching with your bros or your girls
you can do that with draftkings
sportsbook america's top rated
sportsbook app if you haven't checked
out yet
uh there's no better time to sign up and
start cashing in
to celebrate the most exciting time of
the football season my favorite time by
far
draftkings has given you the chance to
double your money all it takes is one
touchdown to be scored during saturday's
football games that's right
once you opt in and place your bet all
you have to do is sit back and wait for
a touchdown
while we're all excited for football
let's not forget the 2021 basketball
season has kicked off
so head to the app now to check out all
of draftkings daily odd boosts
draftkings is safe secure reliable make
it easy for you to deposit withdraw your
money at your convenience
listen you got ufc coming up you got the
nfl playoffs wild card playoffs
divisional games
you got freaking bcs balls coming up
make money with all this man download
the top rated draftking sportsbook app
now use the prone code cats when you
sign up to have a shot at doubling your
money if a touchdown is scored
in one of saturday's football games
guarantees this touchdown scored so
you're making money
that's code kats for new players to get
a shot at doubling their money for
limited time
only at draftkings sportsbook must be 21
and older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details
gambling prom cool call 1-800 gambler or
in
indiana 1-809 with it listen man a lot
of y'all went out
partying for the new year's you're
bringing 2021 in the same way
you like to drink that's cool but you
got to stay hydrated that's why i'm here
to tell you about liquid iv
and their popular hydration drink mix
their energy multiplier
is an absolute game changer gives you a
little extra boost we all need
i think we can all agree 2020 was rough
it's time to clean and slate and start
with a clean slate i don't know why they
wrote it that way
start 20 21 off with the right foot one
stick
of liquid iv is like drinking two cups
of coffee and it's an all natural
alternative
to process energy drinks for a sustained
energy boost throughout the day
all right half americans report that
they struggle with daily fatigue
that's why liquid iv energy multiplayer
can upgrade your vibe
and reach you in a constant state of
awesomeness
all right i love liquid iv i take it all
the
freaking time i get off my bike this one
i'm guzzling down to keep this thick
body hydrated
they got you covered man liquid iv uh
listen liquid ivs fantastic tastes good
enhance uh rapid absorption into the
bloodstream gives you long-lasting
energy boosts fast
powers your mornings you want to start
your mornings off with it we're talking
about that energy multiplier man maybe
you ditch the coffee maybe try this
liquid iv is available nationwide at
costco's or
you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidity.com
and use the code kats at checkout that's
25
off anything you order when you use the
code kats
liquidity.com start fueling your
adventures today at liquidity.com promo
code kats
another debate club
the oh brendan uh
debate club um aliens
uh is this [ __ ] all real uh is it
[ __ ]
um you know all this information that
that looks like he's hiding from the
government's supposedly
his energy is gonna be disclosing to us
slowly
is that real or are they just you know
further trying to hide
stuff from us you're making a lot more
money now if i had the real answer
yeah we know man we know podcasters now
dude we know ask your boy alex jones are
you guys besties now do you text on a
daily basis oh no no i like alex but
he's too much
it's just too much never meet your
heroes yeah
it's a lot it's like he's a lot and
sometimes you just can't do it
no he'll be like you know there's a
globalist invasion i'm like
dude you want to eat man yeah i'm trying
to breakfast
it's a globalist invasion all the time i
respect that
he's done some horrible things too so
it's also very hard
he's done a lot of things right very
hard he's done a lot a guy like that
predicted epstein before anyone else did
and then gets no credit for it oh he
just gets [ __ ] on he has no credit for
it however
then he also was like you know hey maybe
sandy hook didn't happen and everyone's
like no it did
uh so it like evens out and it like
evens out where it's like still he looks
very bad
very bad and it's whatevs like he's a
conspiracy guy like he's gonna look at
everything and gone maybe
that didn't happen he's the conspiracy
guy the guy in america him and sam
tripley
yeah and it's just tough man it's a
tough gig right it's not easy
well no because also those guys they
don't believe anything they don't
you can't you can't have a natural
conversation yeah but the thing about
aliens is like to me i was never got an
alien i was bored yeah me too i was
boring
gives a [ __ ] i mean i think they're out
there in point it's not even a good
conspiracy because there's like nothing
no one has any proof i'd rather talk
about a conspiracy that like
affects people like like that actually
you could find
evidence like is michelle obama a man
yes like
things like that but aliens i'm like
yeah maybe yeah
unless someone comes down i look like he
had just outran the cops
uh and he's like he'd gotten away from
like
what he's like before i go away let me
submit this [ __ ] singer's thing
before i just have a lawyer argue this
down to petty larceny let me just get
this alien question
off my chest i mean he looks like he
just tried to steal a rim from like an
auto zone or something
and he's now behind the building he's
just super quiet
another debate club hey guys
this is caroline from gastonia north
carolina i heard tim dillon is going to
be hosting the show this week and i know
he's an ice cream connoisseur so i have
a question
ice cream ben and jerry's or haagen-dazs
i heard her
ben and jerry's that's a great question
you're an ice cream connoisseur it's
great
have you had
have you had uh like salt and straw or
uh jenny's of course
okay of course carry on no i've i've
been i've had incidents in soul straw
you having trouble insulting what's
wrong with you no it's what's wrong with
them
the problem is he spit on a salt and
strawberry no
but the problem is sometimes it's salt
and straw enough with the testing
of the people in front of me like one
person out man
and i start i start kind of getting
aggressive like where i'm like
what's this yeah it's vanilla yeah it's
vanilla eat it or i i want to [ __ ]
start
you know soul sure i like but they get a
little too aggressive with
uh they're like they get very they get
aggressive like they put thanksgiving
stuffing in the ice cream yeah some of
the yellows are too crazy
yeah you know they're like we want to do
a uh ice cream for flag day it's like
shut the [ __ ] up just put cookie dough
in it and let's go
um this young woman asked me uh ben and
jerry's and hugging us number one so
what unites them both right
they're both super premium brands of ice
cream meaning that
they're dense right so when you have
like turkey hill
or you just just imagine me saying
that's too like just the icu of just fat
coronavirus
breaking down you do a ted talking ice
cream like
actually but when you do turkey or eeds
they're whipped and they have a lot more
air in them they're not super premium so
the reason that the haagen-dazs and
benjamins are packed in pints are super
premium ice cream
uh haagen-dazs is made with like five
ingredients benadryl's has a few more
but they're still
pretty similar the difference between
haagen-dazs and ben jerry's is this
ben and jerry's and i had a joke about
this has too much going on
in the ben and jerry's ice cream what do
you mean like the jay garcia too much
i love the juice i know but that's okay
you were raised where
denver correct so the problem is you're
from where long island new york
that's where the vanderbilts live this
is we are the highest end people that
have ever lived
that's where the culture of ordered
people the country started in long
island i mean money started in long
island class started in long island
okay so uh haagen-dazs has a cleaner
finish better flavors of actually ben
and jerry's is more fun
it's more fun if you're high but overall
quality of ice cream
hagidas is better is a better quality
ice cream it's a better word what's your
favorite
what's your favorite with your
ingredients which would like if you go
to sausage
you get a white chocolate raspberry
truffle is a beast that's a super beast
it's pretty fancy it's white chocolate
with raspberry
and i get it yeah i'm in it's really
good and if i go to salt and straw that
a salted malted uh cookie dough is one
of the best
and then i get it fudge on top yeah me
too i mean that is probably the best
flavor right now in america as a salted
maltese and cookie dough at
salt and straw but thank you for your
question good question
nice damn you know your ice cream i do
you ever [ __ ] with that keto ice cream
i remember rebel and enlightened yeah
yeah they taste like icing
yeah yeah it does it's no good it's
pronounced it's better to just not
[ __ ] with any of that agree i was full
of keto when i started eating like a
keto cookie
from a place and then i'm like oh this
is not
this is not it king in the sting
jack coming to you from northampton
massachusetts
uh lesbian capital of the country huge
fan
and i got a debate club for you guys
who is the worst tweeter
could it be being dad or would it be
ruth conda forever mom
if you're unfamiliar i sent my man nick
some screenshots
i know about beandown just a terrible
parent what's the other one
uh ruth conda forever it was here we go
uh
what a weird question this guy
interesting though it's interesting but
so very specific for the listener that i
know bean dad has a daughter
i guess he's a podcast like musician guy
and so he has a daughter
and she wanted to open up beans beans
and then he was like well you need to
figure out how to do it on your own with
the
can opener right and it took her six
hours which is alarming
took her six hours she's 12 or something
nine nine nine
took her like six hours she was starving
she was crying and throwing fits
yeah and he was like well you need to
figure this out this is life yeah
he sounds fun yeah he sounds like a
great sounds like a real problem i think
my problem will be on like she'll be
like doing [ __ ] she'll be on only
fans in four years
selling her [ __ ] for [ __ ] you know
adderall
and he'll be like i don't know where i
went wrong i i spent nine hours watching
my problem is what kind of dad thinks
it's smart to go on twitter and tell
everyone what you did
yeah and then he apologized which is
also the worst thing you could do though
i actually apologize
so just told my father so this is the
wakanda mom just told my ten-year-old
daughter about
uh rbg who passed away she had tears in
her eyes and then
she did the wakanda pose and said ruth
conda forever which is sort of popcorn
now this woman's worse
oh wow yes she's worse this woman's
muscle she's not even a question
no she yeah this woman [ __ ] sucks
dude that first of all your ten-year-old
daughter that never happened you made
this entire situation entire thing up
i i like uh hillary baldwin better than
this lady yeah this lady sucks
hilarious we call it hillary okay are
you a fan of hilarious she's from the
world
i'm all for it let me pretend to be a
different race i think it's great
who cares who does that bother you what
kind of loser are you
if somebody came up to me they're like
do you know this [ __ ] isn't really
russian i'd go
oh yeah i don't care i don't give a [ __ ]
she likes russians yeah all right she
wants to speak in russia
i don't understand why people get upset
about this [ __ ] i think it's great
i think it's fun i don't know why people
are mad i don't give a [ __ ]
i think she also was doing she was like
a high-class hispanic lady she wasn't
trying to she's not an ms-13
she's not like trying to be a [ __ ]
gangbanger no she was on good morning
america
yeah [ __ ] foreign
yes white with a little spice to me is
fine to separate herself from the masses
i would get it it would be a little
weird if she was trying to be a maid
you know like she's like alec boulder's
wife hilaria pretending to be a maid and
she was like
you know like that would be weird i
guess where it gets diced is alex
baldwin met her in a restaurant
and she's pretending she's spanish and
doesn't know who he is
he's like i'm not from here i don't know
who you are
well he's also a psychopath right so i
mean what who does he think he's
attracted but also
when they lay down at night because
they've been together for like [ __ ]
12 years
he you know damn well he was like oh
this [ __ ] isn't from spain
come on man right no he's punched her in
the face
he's definitely better but this uh
alexandra lee caps is by far the worst
she's cause she made this entire thing
up
uh but then people started digging into
john roderick was the bean dad guy
and he had a bunch of like anti-semitic
tweets and stuff uh this one right here
uh he replied to someone you said the
fourth has been perverted by
activist uh jew and mud people apologist
now it's heating up yeah that's not even
really a
joke no that's pure racism that's real
hate
that's a philosophy yeah that's bad now
he's also best friends with the guy from
uh
jeopardy who is also taking some heat
for saying some racist tools uh he's uh
uh jennings that's a podcast he does a
podcast with ked jennings uh and then
yeah some people like
ken jennings has like off color tweets
nothing like that no like no
there's no humor in there his was about
gays and um
and uh uh mentally this guy deleted his
twitter john
roderick he got rid of his twitter he
had another one he said uh
and i'm quoting him uh i object to
people who say
or the for to the people who say object
when i say gay or [ __ ] it just
reminds me how gay
gay and [ __ ] they are that's tough
or how they're gay retards or something
yeah that's i mean that's just kind of a
stupid thing he's good at jeff he's good
at jeopardy
shoes like that that's a little wild
yeah
yeah too much so are we leaning back
towards bean dad is the worst
no no no still the mockery made the
entire situation up
and then decided to go to twitter to get
likes yeah no she's still worse
all right uh let's move on to a rip my
drip
uh this one's really involved kind of
goes back to rip my drip is i get it
it's got
their clothes right i didn't know you're
from you're from you know
listen to my god i don't want to know
this i did that one year of community
when i leave
yo what's up king and the sting this is
mike here at my bike shop in downtown
denver colorado called bike shop on 21st
and curtis
this is rip my drip go ahead and check
this out it's a
five farm straight from the 90s edition
all right
vintage all vintage we got the movado
one we got the eddie bowers and we've
got the timberlands on
all right now this special shirt right
here it's got a little hidden pocket
right here
for your lighter whatever you need they
don't make them like this anymore look
at the cut
see that cut see how it hangs down i
don't make them like this anymore man
this g-shit
all right i'll check these out all right
this might rip my drip shoes right here
now these are 1996 packer reebok
collaboration for the 1996 all-star
nba game can't excuse
come on bro come on and join me next
time for a little bit of
tune my room where you guys help me you
know add additions to my room and stuff
like that i got a collection upstairs
exhibit before we go though hold up we
got that 25th anniversary
vintage 1990s disney original come on
bro
that's part of my collection i got it i
didn't think it was that bad it's
getting worse and worse
like incredibly quickly
at the beginning i'm like okay you know
i was like all right well he just looks
like he shops at t.j.maxx
probably has the old chicken i mean 25th
anniversary disney world thing
i mean there's just no excuse for that
there's no excuse for that
though the whole outfit is just a hot
mess man 1996 was the best year of his
life because 25 years ago was
when the package was like a shirt that
like you know making a murderer on
netflix
yeah a shirt that like a member of the
family wears to court
you know they come in like a disney
shirt and the lawyer's like yeah we
can you do anything else do you have a
partner yeah they're like you wear
anything else and he's like yeah let me
get this fat farm button up on
you know what just leave just wear that
disney yeah that fat
farm uh denim whenever you see somebody
in a denim shirt you go this is
someone no i like denim no i like it
yeah i like denim uh you can't do denim
with denim with
jeans though well you can't do a texas i
just feel like i feel like when i see a
big guy
maybe it's me but when i see a big guy
in a denim jacket
i go there's a guy that needs a cop
present to see his daughter
there's a guy who's visitational rights
with this yeah yeah that
that's a problem i considered a big guy
no like i'm talking about fat guy denim
jacket oh
gotcha do you like denim jackets i love
denim i can't maybe i should get into
denim
i think you look sweet in denim i might
you know too many people have dissuaded
me from denim
yeah you gotta hang out the right people
man so i could pull off you think a
black denim jacket [ __ ] yeah you look
sweet in that
wow yeah you'd look sick in that all
right you know i might be doing that
the video you did as the influencer i
mean i looked
great it didn't look bad no i looked
what video was it i looked [ __ ]
amazing
what's the title of it uh uh
uh i i don't know if it's a title i mean
there is a title
i don't i don't remember it it's on my
youtube or something it's how long ago
was yeah i mean i looked dope i looked
dope as [ __ ]
dude look how dark i look i looked up in
the baby
i look sad
yeah where i was giving that mustard to
homeless people
because like a lot of these kids are
giving out like bottles of water and
[ __ ] to homeless people
was it honey dijon at least yeah it was
no it was nice it was like a uh i don't
know
it was uh like a straight mustard
there's like a stone ground
that's not bad not bad but i that bay
pudding man when i put it on dude
a black guy came up to me in bay because
you look fly as [ __ ] right now
and dude i'd never felt better in my
life because the fit is fresh
and dude there was like little kids
looking at me like [ __ ] yeah man like
stay cool dude hypebeast i didn't know
this there's hypebeasts that are like
four
like oh yeah hypebeasts are like literal
children that are like in
[ __ ] vape yeah man they're like 12
years old
it's real they've been waiting for like
nine hours to get a shirt so they can
resell it
but it's a community like i feel you'd
look cool in a black denim jacket
and some like uh dad yeezys yeah i might
do that dude
i don't give a [ __ ] maybe i'll get you
those yeezys just as a friend
i appreciate what size should you wear
thirteen you wear thirteen thirteen
so do i you can i got you i'll do it
i'm going back to bait i think i'm gonna
go back to get another i want another
hood
and they're not cheap they're like 450
they're not changing and you know what's
crazy the hood is so big
then it looks like you have the mouth on
it yeah it's good and it's got this big
alien in the back i mean
dude but you i don't know it's like you
put one of those on you're like oh yeah
[ __ ] it i could be this person now
it's kind of cool but i don't feel like
you can drop an emboss yeah you're like
i could just say the n-word
and drive around it's going to be like
when christol uh
told rappers not to drink uh the ceo
told him not to drink it they're gonna
ask you to stop wearing it because it's
a bad look for him
right right they're like i think it's a
good look for them though gucci did that
yeah a whole new audience
it's for well vape is really just for
like
[ __ ] fat hypebeasts that's what vape
is for it's like for crazy hype
it's real yeah out of shape boys yeah
it's like not you know
uh this guy's got a relationship advice
question open a nice set of eyebrows
from colorado shout out brennan um
here's uh i guess debate club slash
relationship advice
um right now i'm currently talking to
this girl so i hope no one watches the
show that i know
but anyways i'm currently talking to
this girl and we're only 18.
okay and her body count or whatever you
want to call it hookups is seven
so like from a girl's perspective cat
like what number is too high for you to
like kind of like stir you away
or just like what are you guys thoughts
on that in general uh keep doing you
guys think i love the show
okay well he looks 38 yeah she's like
every bit of 34.
number one every bit of divorce
the fact you're 18 is terrifying you you
don't need to focus on anyone's body
count
you need to just focus on the fact that
you are lying about your age
and no one is buying it no we should
what do you think 18 year old girls
sleep with seven dudes this doesn't seem
like it's that much maybe it is i don't
know but that's what kids do especially
like how much in euphoria you know
they're transgenders there's dads
[ __ ]
like it's it's a lot man that's why kids
they do xc
they [ __ ] each other it's like shaking
hands they don't care
seven ain't [ __ ] dude yeah relax dude
also you want like
70. you better be happy what you can get
that'll be
happy she's calling you back uh yeah
it's what they do man
it's it's what kids do these days uh
seven and she's 18 he said
yeah that's not a big deal dude don't
look too into it also you want to test
drive the car man you still want to
commit to a car without test driving it
also you're 41 years old why are you
playing
something wrong it's like 21 jump street
or something yeah
uh let's move on some king understing it
what up boys darius stars well coming to
you live from minneapolis minnesota
we out here on the ice with it highway
nice kids i can't understand skating on
the pond when it gets cold enough
i feel like y'all got them skinny ass
legs so you probably can't hang with it
brandon you're way too beef you find
yourself on some slick [ __ ] like this so
fast let me know what y'all think
culture culture and much love
gang gang skate skate we out that looks
like a hypeboy on the on the
pond there yeah man that guy is [ __ ]
he is talking
uh he's talking black
god he does it well like he does it well
where it's like you it's okay
somehow that's okay like if a white
woman dresses like a cow or an indian a
coachella everyone goes nuts
but like a white guy can be like yeah
get with it we with it we whit it on ice
son
son i'd be like with it i'd be like gang
gang boom boom chug chug chug
chug chug i came out i i knew where it
drove when he had the fake
uh what was that what what's that uh
dude this
burberry yeah the fake bourbon burberry
scarf
and he's just like that color or jacket
is out of control
and he's just like on a lake in uh
minnesota god bless him he's like a good
guy
how does like a guy's a good guy how do
we know it's fake because that does look
like a rich neighborhood
in minnesota doesn't it
that he took and she's literally like
where's my scarf
and he's like you know i need that fit
also
i need that [ __ ] son he calls her son
he's like yo son
i need that fish she's like my name is
your mother i'm your mom
i'm your mother call me [ __ ] and yeah
you need to get a job and not skate on
that lake by our house all day
it's embarrassing you need to get back
on the [ __ ] zamboni man yeah
he uh is that a nice neighborhood in
minnesota nick because
minnesota all looks the same it's like
upper upper middle class i guess yeah
those houses are 85
that's a nice neighborhood those houses
are a hundred and thirteen dollars it's
on a lake this guy's been out of rehab
for like two weeks he's like i feel good
you know i got that fit i'm on the ice
son
but so ice skating do you have you guys
done it as a child [ __ ] ice skating on a
random
[ __ ] i'm with him i'm too big for
that man minnesota what's he gonna fall
in he's gonna be rescued by a bunch of
somalis
because it's a huge population they are
the captain now
yeah i don't know man hard pass for me
sting
it we're stinging ice skating sting
today's king this thing with tim dillon
is brought to you by athletic greens the
most comprehensive daily nutritional
beverage
i've ever had it's green so you know
it's healthy tastes delicious
all you do is mix a little scoop in
there shake it up boom you're getting
athletic greens
talking about 75 vitamins minerals whole
foods source ingredients
including a multivitamin multi-mineral
probiotic
they got it all man listen whatever diet
you're on there's some gaps in that diet
let us help you out man athletic greens
is obsessed with keeping you healthy
right now i thought greens is doubling
down on supporting your immune system
because you need it you need it it's the
winter
cove is popping during the winter months
it's not fun man so athletic greens
are offering you guys a free one-year
supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase if you visit
the link today you basically never have
to buy vitamin d again just forget about
it
simply visit athleticgreens.com cats
join the health experts athletes health
conscious go-getters around the world
who make a daily commitment to their
health every freaking day
again all you got to do go to
athleticgreens.com
kats get your free year supply of
vitamin d
five free travel packs today athletic
greens.com
k-a-t-s listen man y'all be crazy
a lot of y'all get sad 2020 2021 is here
let somebody help you i'm not talking
about your buddy who's all
you know reading a lot of books thinks
he can help you out his life is in
shambles his light bill got cut off
nope don't do that man start talking
about to a licensed professional
talking about better help they're going
to assist you with your needs and match
you with your own license
profession now therapists right you can
start communicating under 48 hours
not crisis science not self-help we're
talking about real professional
counseling done securely on line
service available worldwide dog world
freaking wide
log on anytime send a message to your
counselor whatever you got going on
they're going to help you out
but help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy
and free to change counselors if not
feeling the one they prescribe to you
all right it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling
financial aid is available better help
once you start living a happier life
today all right in fact so many people
have been using better help
they're recruiting an additional
counselors in all 50 states
special offer for you king and the sting
listeners get 10 for your first month
at betterhelp.com k-a-t-s betterhelp.com
cats let's see
clearly this guy looks like a follower
that looks like a domestic terrorist
clearly this guy's a fan of jerry garcia
ice cream as well
and theo it's your boy chris hippy davis
from st louis missouri
got a king intersting it for you uh
the good old grateful dead there you go
brendan i know you [ __ ] with them
yup yeah they're great but uh theo
what's your opinion
buzz buzz uh jerry garcia theo's not
here but his brother has a tattoo on his
chest right who has a problem with a
grateful dad
have you ever listened to music though
yeah it's the songs are 18 minutes long
they're very long because you got to be
on drugs really high yeah yeah
but i mean have you been to a concert
grateful dad
no it'd be a hard pass for me i love
their shoes the collabs they did with
the nike dunks are great i love their
merch
songs are too long you got to be on
drugs to get down with the concerts
also how did jerry garcia die
i mean he was obese but
do you know how i have no clue yeah i'm
not a big guy i just think he was old it
ran its course
i don't he died pretty young heart
attack and then john mayer was uh they
took over the band
you know how that korean kid took over
journey that's what john mayer did with
filipino oh yeah the filipino dad was
good they were never my favorite i was
always more like i like the who or the
rolling stones or the beatles more so
than the dad
see man now charles manson would say
otherwise everyone thinks he was a big
beatles fan he was a big uh grateful
dead fan
interesting why i know that i don't know
interesting
what up brandon what up theo kat nick
chappelle chin what's up everybody uh i
just got a little king interesting for
you i've been out here
running these grocery games shopping for
people
out here at the grocery store i want to
hear what you guys think king
or stinging paying for somebody to go
get your own groceries
love the show guys wait what take it
easy you mean like post baits yeah
uh yeah like postmates groceries amazon
delivery you mean king understand like a
major sector of the economy now
yeah what is this guy doing he's like
king of her stinging drinking water
what do you guys think you know keegan
are seeing it seeing a movie in a
theater
it's like yeah we're that's pretty much
an accepted way of doing business
those are the type of ones we get yeah
i'm sorry no one else is here now i
realize how important it is to have all
the other people here
but i'm paranoid about corona and every
show i do at brendan he's got 35 asian
people here in the room
and i'm like do we really need that la's
literally burning down
but asia is fine haven't seen muhammad i
know but i know but that's why they'll
give it to me they're all immune they'll
give it to me i just don't need it
i don't need 15 bts koreans in here
while i'm performing thank you that's
all respect
i'm either with asians or black guys
yeah it's always some minority that's
being disproportionately affected by
golfing
brenda's like yeah we're just doing it
you know we've got 19 producers they all
take the bus here
like i'd rather not thank you i'd rather
not welcome from chinatown yeah welcome
to chinatown they're fine they've all
had it nineteen times i'm like that
doesn't make me feel good
it was they left it fifty times they
were taking lunch orders now you're cool
with batsuit
so well you know i apologize i see that
there's an investment these people want
them to answer i get it but i'll try to
answer for all of them
yeah please do yeah but i mean postmates
dude it's
the world now it's the world tim's point
i mean come on
yeah man it's nice i'm [ __ ] king it
man that's what we have to do
brandon theo rest of the crew what's
going on it's your boy clay from ohio
uh i got a king her stinging for you i
just went and dropped my buck off at the
old uh taxidermy to get it done you know
and uh
i start coming down the hill realizing
i'm going the wrong way
so i'm like all right i'll turn around
so i gotta turn around it's snowy here
in ohio
i get stuck in the man's driveway
screwed
by myself so i'm trying to push it out
i'm hot i'm flustered
i'm pissed off either way this nice
gentleman pulls up
i'm standing on the corner like a tooth
like a prostitute as theo would say
and uh he's like you need some help more
information
of course i do man can't you see that
i'm pushing my vehicle
and uh yeah so the dude jumps out of the
car
loki looks like joe exotic from tiger
king but hey i'm not judging i'm in a
tough spot
so either way the man pulls me out we're
good to go
i'm glad he didn't ask me to come over
or anything like that that'd be weird
but either way
king or sting it helping people on the
side of the road
would you stop or wouldn't you stop gang
gang was the entire audience
going to or coming back from rehab
yeah they're all steel fans this is
every archetype of person i was in rehab
with
what the [ __ ] they're like king in the
stinger helping ladies cross the road
yes or no i mean i'm like i don't know
man i don't i don't have any skills to
help people on the side of the road i
don't drive a pickup truck what do you
want me to do it's all so
dizzy helping people these days man is
it a setup
i've seen too many first 48s i love this
guys
he's like that could have been awkward
yeah it could have been weird you know
i'm just on the side of the road looking
[ __ ] pretty damn good
in my [ __ ] uh weird farmer shirt and
my hoodie
and my backwards hat and you know
thinking about why i [ __ ] got fired
from perkins last week
it's like a middle american pirate yeah
he's like i thought
he worked at perkins
no matter what you order you order
pancakes the morning you get a free pie
it's like
nice wow they've gone out of business
like i think dude that's what i'd go on
the road i'd just eat at perkins early
in the day just go to bed for like five
hours
and then wake up and like didn't know
where i was i'm like what and i'm like i
have a show in an hour
and a lemon meringue pie yeah just
eating [ __ ] french silk pie
of all the chain diners i i like i'm
proud of perkins
is there shonies out shoni says great
strawberry yeah yeah
uh no i've in cocos
uh these sound higher end what about you
you're not helping anyone on the street
no no uh it's i've just seen if
ah man if it's like a dude's dude and
like his car is [ __ ] up and it's like
we're in the middle of nowhere i help
him out but if it's like off sunset
it's too dicey man like [ __ ] triple a
dude
especially if i'm with my kids i'm not
stopping man again i've seen way too
much cold cases in the first 48 yeah too
much i know how this ends
but i'm not going to assume everybody's
trying to [ __ ] me like this guy right
this guy's a little out of his mouth
yeah take it easy bubba
and i think there's part of him that
wanted to the guy wanted
he's like yeah he didn't ask me to come
over that was weird i i wouldn't have
done it but i just would have
appreciated you the ask you know
i wanted to see what i was made of i uh
the other day on new year's eve day i
went to the bank
and it was closed uh u.s bank
and so find this picture there was this
old couple there they didn't speak like
great english they were russian
and uh they were like oh super bummed
out like she looked like she was gonna
cry because it was cold i was like
i'm going to the other one like on
larchmont or something
you guys want to come with me and
they're like oh yes they were all
excited and then
that one was closed we ended up being in
the car for like an hour did they rob
you uh no they were just a really nice
old russian couple who lived in ohio for
a while lisa and gary they were they
were
really nice people um i actually have a
picture of us
but so i can need the pers it's a cute
picture let me
see
i mean obviously king helping people oh
wow
there's lisa and gary what are you what
are you doing with them uh we went to
the bank
and why uh i don't know they really
needed to deposit a check
we also have an idiot accountant who
can't do direct deposits for some reason
really
i don't know it's a nice channel
sometimes i see an elderly person
struggling and i stare at them
yeah i don't trust anybody so sting yeah
sorry clay
all right another king interesting it
saw dudes what's up all right um my name
is zianja i'm from scottsdale arizona
and i have a king that or sting it for
you so a little backstory i was in the
peace corps living in swaziland prior to
covid
and out there i just stopped giving a
[ __ ] about
body hair so king or stinger girls with
armpit hair
oh no
all right ding gang buzz buzz oh
hard pass is disgusting
again are you mantin's favorite girl in
the troupe what are you doing man
yeah armpit here for women yeah that's
the one thing right
when she said peace corps how hot you
are if you have
uh here oh no i'm out
and that's a pretty girl i'm out i'm out
hard [ __ ] pass couldn't sting that
hard enough
what about men what what about hairy men
tim you're like hairy man no
not really but i mean men have hair
which is normal yeah but
too much hair is is not good yeah like a
hairy russian yeah i like the opposite
of me
so i don't want like a hairy person i
don't want russians either you can't
trust them
that's fair they don't have souls
russians they have beautiful eyes like
huskies
yeah there's nothing behind them yep 100
years of cold blue eyes 100 years of
forced atheism
they don't have any souls but yeah women
with armpit hair
i'm like kind of disturbed by that put a
little pride into it man
care that's disgusting oh my god it's
theo's cousin
what's up brendan what's up theo what's
up culture corner
pat chin nick we got a debate club for
you
we talking chopsticks with these sushi
hitters great what's going on
i mean for me i'm saying forget these
i'm just going in with my hands of
course you are
talking about it looks like an extra
stranger things
yeah he does he looks like the guy that
wasn't good looking enough to get the
stranger things roll
and he's now at sushi
well i had a trip to l.a that was pretty
cool like he's the guy that they bring
out for stranger things and one of the
directors goes are you high
yeah putting him on television like you
said earthy real
and they're like too real too worthy get
someone else uh
yeah i like chopsticks i do too man yeah
they're pretty [ __ ] easy to figure
out but also where's he eating indoor
it has to be florida oh he's not out
here
no yeah that was the weird thing when i
was in florida looking at these savages
inside restaurants eating like yeah
or whatever it just we it's
weird-looking it's weird man i guess
people just don't care and then i get it
because people have to go out and work
right and
the government didn't give anyone any
money you know i don't know it's just
i just know that there's a lot of weird
[ __ ] going on with this where it's like
i don't know what this
is i don't know have you talked to alex
jones about the conspiracy of covid
yeah i think a lot of people think it's
he gets way too deep but i think a lot
of people think it's just something that
was made in a lab
i don't even think that's a
controversial statement now no i think
they traced it back to being made in a
lab in china
and it just got out just got out and
it's like it's [ __ ] weird you know
it's you know it's disturbing but what
kind of [ __ ] savage
eats sushi with their hands my dad does
i mean she has nine fingers though oh my
omakasi sushi when they bring it out
like one at a time you're supposed to
eat it with your hands
oh really japanese high-end chat but
like it is like japanese
you know seriously you're supposed to
eat it with your hands it's like that's
part of what it is
you know however when you're eating
rolls like that
get your hand out of the plate don't
touch all the right
what are you doing what are you doing
get your [ __ ] hand get your commit
take your [ __ ] mitt out of the sushi
ball
okay okay my girlfriend is
allergic to all fish so we can never get
sushi oh an interesting one
tendency and she's asian dude really
yeah what kind of asian
uh vietnamese that's the lower end
it's just a low rent it's china and
japan with japan china
uh korea and then you start going like
philip well not philippines is the final
one but it's like
vietnamese and then like burma
and then like that like the philippines
like yeah the philippines and by the way
that's not me that's asia
that's from the [ __ ] religion i'm
being honest because i've asked age i
have no opinion i don't care
it's all the same to me validated it no
chin knows that that's right
and here's a bit of philippines remember
there was a tsunami and no one cared
this is a tsunami the philippines was
destroyed and everyone was like shut the
[ __ ] up
no one cares like all right that's where
just everyone goes and hosts like kitty
porn websites
i mean that's just from other asians
this is history though this is what i've
been told
those are facts chin confirmed it and
speaking of the government not giving uh
these businesses money in like three
minutes we're gonna have dave portnoy on
to uh talk about the small his uh bar
stool fund
uh i've seen tim tweet about it that's
not giving enough media it's amazing
that the media doesn't cover because
he's doing a lot of great [ __ ] and it's
just amazing that the media
doesn't cover it all the time like every
day i'm really hoping it passes uh 27
million that's what guy fieri
uh raised at like the beginning of the
pantheon and he's keeping like
restaurants and stuff open is that what
he's doing with it yeah like people are
just like
uh getting nominated or nominating their
own business and they're kind of like
giving a number of how much they need to
like run it out for a couple months
and then uh yeah it's just one business
after another and like
zero administration costs so everything
that gets donated are those frauds at
ruth chris
being like hey we need help man we need
50 million
yeah probably yeah uh they have some way
of
it's like the rules that you got to be
small business i think it's
certain number of employees and then you
have to have your payroll on so it's not
just like the owners that are reaping
the benefits
that's cool um but uh you like roost
chris don't you
no no oh that's the one i don't like
with chris i love corn
did you get kicked out of ruth chris no
i don't have i've never known
it's pretty basic but i love uh you're
like capital grill
capital grill spent the sports keys
fleming's all that [ __ ] i love just the
ocean prime the the archetype of a
corporate steakhouse a nameless faceless
corporate entity that has hot rolls
steak pretty
sides that's what i like it's bell
frisco love it
love it you get are you a filet guy or
you you go proud i go wherever i like
new york
new york strip is my favorite cup bone
in new york strip rib eyes are too fatty
fillets are too lean a bone in new york
strip is perfect that's where all the
flavors at flavorful
the bones the key man that's where all
the flavor comes from
yes and i'm [ __ ] starving
so we got we got portenoid coming on to
talk about raising more money
yep uh we got a lot of hot chicas this
episode
yeah tim comes on and all the ch chicks
come out this is
i believe a man please don't have it hi
brendan hi theo
it's britta from minneapolis nick shout
out
fellow umn alum sky you my baby
go ghosts i got a debate
so back in the day as a kid when you
went to the dentist you had to do those
awful fluoride trays
yeah and they would offer you different
flavors were you the type of kid that
played it safe and went with
mint or did you pick an exotic flavor
like
banana split or bubble gum i did apples
i always picked orange that was my
personal favorite but i want to know
what's better play it safe with mint or
pick one of the fun flavors
gang gang buzz bun [ __ ] marry me theo
put your teeth
you're not supposed to swallow it i went
grape every time i did apple cinnamon
apple cinnamon yeah oh that's kind of
weird
that is kind of weird but grape i
thought was the absolute worst grape is
horrible
yeah i went with grape every time for
some reason it's apple cinema is not
good either
yeah none of them are good and they're
all pretty sour and mint is rough too
and why can't i [ __ ] swallow it man
why was it such a big deal if i
swallowed that [ __ ] yeah it is crazy
they put something in your mouth that
you're not supposed to be able to
swallow i don't think they still do
that [ __ ] trays anymore do they uh
trace like the fluoride trays i think
that's a thing of the past
possibly i don't know but now i want it
now i kind of actually want it you miss
it
now that we talked about it i kind of
actually want it when's the last time
you guys had your teeth cleaned
do you go last year i went and i'm
trying to think uh
where i got it clear where where was i i
got a dental hygiene i was in l.a
did you have any problems i was in new
york i was in new york for a week and i
got a dentist and
i had no cavities or anything wow i went
probably eight years ago and she goes
man you have uh
you you genetically your teeth are
amazing you know because i haven't gone
to dentists forever and she goes they're
really clean
and i went oh you [ __ ] up i haven't
been back since
i just i'm just my dad once in the 80s
he went in and they're like yeah
you're it's like four grand and he just
got up and said [ __ ] you
i like you need four grand worth of work
when they're like
no you really need it yeah i [ __ ] up i
could add braces my grandma would have
sacrificed and like paid for them
but i was like i don't want to go
through middle school with braces but
now i have four
teeth and i'm an adult how about how bad
are you get uh invisalign
uh i don't think it'll work now because
i have a bridge i had the accident i've
spoke about one time on here where i
ripped my tooth out on a basketball net
so now these three never heard that
story uh these three teeth are all
connected
uh it's a bridge so i know invisalign
for you uh one day i wanted to uh just
hit up joe coy's doctor he said it was
60 grand he has perfect teeth
60 grams every tooth like implant
perfect like and they gotta file down
the teeth for veneers bubba
they gotta file them down it's a little
insane yeah and then you look
ridiculous with these [ __ ] big pearly
whites uh
they can they can like kind of yellow
them a little bit they look natural i
don't know his teeth look great one day
would you do veneers to him maybe just
to make it easy
yeah i just don't want them to file my
teeth down
how's life out there in uh new york city
my man
sucks is it bad i've been i heard it's
better than
la though
that was worse actually when i was there
but that was before they canceled indoor
dining
yeah i i'm surprised i guess i'm just
surprised to hear that
which leads us to you launching this
whole kind of fundraiser help out these
small businesses
how'd this idea come about we did a
little background on it but i want to
hear it from the horse's mouth
yeah so you know i was ranting raven
which i tended to do
uh and it was actually i was at the pool
in miami it was when
indoor dining got shut down in new york
and i went out and made like an
instagram video
basically just saying i don't understand
what they expect these small businesses
specifically restaurants bars to do
because they're already on their last
legs and now you're not letting them do
indoor dining it's the middle of winter
in new york
so what's going to happen you got to do
one thing you let them
open up and serve or you got to give
them a lot of money
from the government or else they're just
going to go out of business so that was
the gist of the rant
um and then i got challenged basically
it's like
this guy marcus lemonis was like hey big
mouth put your money where your mouth is
if you're gonna talk about it so that's
what we did so i donated 500 grand
to what we call the bar stool fund and
we said hey if you're a small
business owner and you need help contact
us and then we
basically solicited donations from our
readers i twitter shane
some of my friends who are wealthy and
we've raised
about 18 million 18 five in about i
don't know 12 days or something
and how do you get all these submissions
and we record the videos
yeah of us telling them and it's kind of
taking on a life of its own
and how do you vet the small businesses
that get it because i'm sure there's
some shysters out there
yeah you know it so here's the process
we get emails
and there's two requirements one you
gotta prove you're running a successful
business
before the pandemic and then we assume
you can go back to it after
and your payroll has to be on still
paying employees so those are the two
things we look for
and then we get emails with the stories
videos we have a team led by
this uh woman liz gonzalez who goes
through it it escalates up to me
we talk to the people would you tell
would i be shocked in the span of doing
i think we've done 75 businesses or
something so far
that one or two slipped through
it could happen but i mean our finance
team follows up asks for all the
paperwork
tax rent everything like that
but there's no charity in the history of
charities i don't think
that hasn't been you know stolen from or
whatever i agree i'll take those odds
does it surprise you that the media is
not covering this because this is
probably the most successful
effort to help small businesses during
the whole pandemic
and it just seems like the media should
be reporting on this all the time
and it doesn't seem like that's the case
does that surprise you yeah they don't
give a [ __ ] yeah they seem to not give a
[ __ ]
is that or is it or is there more of
them caring than i've seen i haven't
seen
i've seen like fox you went on fox but i
feel like this is all this does is help
small business owners so you you know
these this is the people that these
people
pretend or should care about i feel like
they should report on this all the time
yeah so fox has covered it and covered
it a decent amount
um and then the local like affiliates of
abc or fox like if we if
a small business is in you know arkansas
the local station will do it
the national besides fox there's been
very little
um and it's stupid like i i did
tweet something out cnn like had a tweet
that beyonce had donated
like i think it was 500 grants
at yeah 105
000 grants so it came out to half a
million dollars basically which is great
and it should everything should get
publicity they haven't mentioned it once
and to me sometimes i think rightly or
wrongly people think i'm political i
always say i don't really think i am i
hate the far left i hate the far right
but in this case it doesn't like we're
helping
all sorts of business i don't know what
their politics it just the more
publicity we get
the louder we can bang the drum the more
donations come in
the more people we can help and we're
never gonna have enough money to help
all the businesses
we're getting 10 000 emails so to me yes
if you care about
small business at all you should
publicize it it can only help
do you do you believe in the conspiracy
that they're trying to get rid of uh
you know those small businesses that's
that's the government's agenda
a lot of people say that and maybe i'm
naive
but i can't belie that that is such a
preposterous thing that like i don't
believe like the vaccine is putting like
chips in people you know
i can't get my head there to think
there's somebody
who would want to put out a business
that has been passed down
generations for like 50 years like that
person if that's true
you should be executed i think it makes
more sense that they're just idiots and
they're
they're enforcing this uh shutdown a
very sloppy and uneven way
and it's hurting a lot of people correct
i think there's no grand design
i don't think there's a grand conspiracy
or a plan i think these people
they're just idiots and they're out of
touch i don't think they have any clue
how affected people really are are like
egotistical selfish self-absorbed people
in general
right and like there's so many side
agendas
and so much self-interest and that's the
problem and that's why something like we
get the money we get it in
that's all we care about so politics
sucks i mean that's
i don't think that's a news flash and
all they care about
is themselves staying in power and
that's it
yep who do you who's mayor you think is
worse ours here with uh
newsome or do you think that la guy kind
of the new york guy sucks
you know they've both done things that
i don't know how they can look
themselves in the mirror to a degree
like when newsom's like you can't go out
and he goes to french laundry it's like
right what the [ __ ] are you doing and
that's not again
political that's like what an [ __ ]
right
is writing books about how [ __ ]
terrifically
he handled this pandemic in the middle
lip pandamic when the city's locked down
like what are you doing he just won an
emmy he won an emmy he wanted
me for killing how about refuse the emmy
yeah like and by the way
we we're a small company and we've
pivoted to doing this
but if you have the money don't have the
money for small business
like the government could set up a
charity and get a ton of not charity but
like a foundation people donate
put a ton of people going through it
effectively to find out who's eligible
like how do you not think of that right
i i don't think people would trust the
government if they
said they were going to do that i think
that's why yours is so successful
because people know where that money's
going to go and i think people trust you
guys will do a lot better of a job
finding actually worthy businesses yeah
i mean there's a lot out there
and it's so the first time we did it
that like the first company and beside
one of them
basically the the person liz who goes
through the email she's like this person
singled out that they really like
barcelona they're a fan of yours
it'd be really cool if you just called
and delivered the news
so i did and i facetimed and and they
broke down
and i wasn't recording it but it was
pretty obvious
like okay i gotta record this because it
was
like very visceral the reaction yeah and
that's what is moving the donations
these videos
is pretty you know i'm not the most like
sensitive guy
but if you watch the videos it's hard
not to be like okay i want to donate to
this
because you can see the weight being
like lifted they're breaking down
yeah so have you have you decided to
help any larger businesses like chipotle
or starbucks
manhattan i mean they need help too i
mean everybody's suffering right ruth
chris
nike yeah no no none of those have
received help
you uh i was just in i was in florida
last week on tour you were in miami last
week
i don't know how bad is in new york but
it was weird seeing uh how florida
there's just a different breed man like
they were eating in restaurants
they were you know i was getting yelled
at because i had a mask
on it was strange so i've been in miami
for every like big event
recently like super bowl art basel you
name it i've been there
it was never busier than it was this
week i agree i mean it was
because everyone's leaving everywhere
else so it's like get me out of new york
get me out of l.a
there's people from all over there i
mean it was madness do you think
something happens
after this pandemic where new york and
la aren't the center of the universes
anymore and do you see
other cities in the country kind of
becoming more interesting and
especially if they raise taxes you think
uh you know there's
more of an entrepreneurial culture it
might be in a place like austin or
nashville or florida
yes like i i do and and i don't know if
that's the goal to a
degree yeah insane i think there's a
real chance
that you know a miami and and the mayor
there
certainly realizes it is wildly
aggressive trying to get companies to go
there
all you hear everyone going to austin um
nashville yeah
some level it's like it seems like a new
york
or an la doesn't want business right
yeah it's very strange and they don't
they don't care when people leave when
these huge businesses leave they don't
they're complacent they've been too big
for too long and i don't think they
you know it's like you know somebody
that's been making money for so long
they forgot
like the you know the ingredients that
made them successful yeah dave have you
thought about leaving new york at all
because in l.a it's a [ __ ] storm like
all our friends left
me and tim are the only ones left yeah
we're it that's him yeah no i
i so i'm going back to miami today and
i'm debating getting a place there
but would you would you move the whole
bar stool operation down there
would but i if enough people here are
like yeah we're behind it
me personally i do in two seconds but
i'm not gonna make like everybody
relocate out there
but if people like yeah let's i'm down
for it i mean the tax difference
i have people every single day now that
i've become a little more successful
with barcelona
we're like you're an idiot like the tax
you're getting murdered in taxes
for what it's like it's so much cheaper
in florida and the weather
and the girls and everything else
fair point yeah it's just better well
great that's a great [ __ ] thing
you're doing and i
i wish that um what can people do if
they want to
give you money so everything is at
barcelon.com that's both
if you're a struggling business you can
submit an application we look for a
video tell your story
and there's a form give us all the info
and if you want donate it's there as
well
and the thing that i just keep stressing
we've raised a lot relatively speaking
but it's really a little for the need
so every dollar matters and the beauty i
think of what we're doing and why we're
doing it
we get the money and we get it out like
the sec within 72 hours of us
contacting the business the money is in
their account that's cool we're not
going away after one month
we're there until the pandemic's done
because what's the point of giving
somebody money
and then three months later they're in
the same spot so it is a good cause
we're doing the best we can um and we're
helping a lot of people you're doing the
lord's work well
we're gonna i don't know if this even
helps at all we're gonna donate five
thousand dollars from king of the sting
to the donation of course it helps
everything helps i appreciate it i'm
gonna
i'm gonna apply for the thousand that
you donated so i hope that even
and we'll see what happens traveling
podcast needs money yes yes
have there uh have have any celebrities
kind of
have have any celebrities jumped on
board and uh got behind this movement
yeah dana white did 100 grand it took
him one second we called him out because
i know him he's like yeah
i think i could have named a million he
would have done it he did it so fast
tom brady did it edelman did it um
kid rock unsolicited called me out of
the blue
donated 100 grand i was on the phone
with sylvester stallone
yesterday um so a lot are coming forward
i want elon musk
well i better elana do it right yeah
infinity money is right up his alley
he just sold all his cribs in uh beverly
hills he had like three of them all next
door he sold all of them now he's in
texas
yeah i tweeted at him but i don't know
him personally
right um i don't need do you know elon i
don't know elon
at all i mean i know i mean i know
obviously you know anyone who's
i've met him i've got him briefly the
closest thing to him that we
was about to say you could you know
rogan has feel free to get him
everyone's hitting me up it seems like
right up his alley feel free to have him
give it a shout out seems like something
he'd be behind too yeah yeah that's a
good point
yeah we'll we'll try yeah i'll try elon
i can't make any promises but i'll text
rogan for you yeah
all right well that's good enough yeah
how have you been able to do your uh
your pizza uh previews show yeah
that that never ends i though those are
daily still going
you've had no problem finding spots and
[ __ ] no because you
you can still get the pizza there now
i'm jealous of that man
because i do a food show but it's not
just me i have to have guests on
because if covet has been a nightmare
have you have you buried the hatchet
with bryce hall i know that you guys
were in uh
he's the softest human of all time
he's a tick-tock literally he like i've
never seen a guy with
thinner skin in my life he's got a hot
you you had a great point you go you got
a hot girlfriend you got all the money
you just enjoy life right yeah a girl
said we said he looked like sid from ice
age he's acting like we called him
hitler it makes no sense
yeah yeah young kids but it's funny
that's a funny podcast he does
with uh he does a podcast with like a
young dave does yeah
yeah yeah younger tick tocker yeah but
it's interesting
the tick tock world's weird right both
strange worlds you boys got into it it's
a very interesting world
there they're mega stars they're like
massive crazy
yes and how long does it last dave
another another 11 months
i don't know i mean i think the big ones
are here to stay like they might be
ray the mellows yeah josh but
the vine stars beg to differ but yeah
yeah well but even if you look like
logan and
logan paul and jake paul they're viners
they're they're they're yeah that's fair
i think that kid josh is really smart
and i think people
like him will figure out a way to stick
around a great
yeah dave are you into like the logan
paul floyd mayweather stuff
and the jake paul fights i am uh
all right so i thought jake paul
would lose to nate robinson because i
was
of the impression i don't care what jake
is like
nate's a professional basketball player
his athletic skill will overwhelm him
you want a dunk
the knockout the way he did it it's like
whoa what just happened
and logan is so much bigger than
floyd and floyd is old now i don't know
the actual
format of how it's going to be like
exhibition but i'm curious and i'm
curious to see
i i thought i thought jake would fight
dylan danis next
that's obviously a much different can of
worms but i would have been interested
i wasn't interested in the first fight
i'll be interested in both there next
me too me too yeah 100 before we get you
out of here dave who
how who do you have win the super ball
and you're a big sports guy
bills the bills yeah josh allen's is
[ __ ] awesome stud
buffalo could use that bubble could use
all the help they can get yeah that will
be their bailout
if the bills win that's all they care
about hey didn't i hear in buffalo
because you know the bill
mafia listen i had a cappuccino with the
buffalo bills i was on the team for
eight days so i can talk like this okay
they i had to try out with them anyway
um the buffalo bills
they're the the bills mafia did didn't
they threaten
like the the governor cuomo like we have
to see the game like sorry
i think they're allowing in like 6500
people or something like that
and i'm sure the tickets are going to be
insane if i don't even know i assume
they're season ticket holders i have no
idea what
how that works but yes i heard they are
requiring
a covid test and they got an official
covid test partner
and you have to pay 60 dollars to this
specific kova testing place
even though there's free ones in new
york so yeah they're kind of
fraud with that yeah yeah zero fraud
dude if
i if i had to get a kova test for every
single restaurant movie theater
sports [ __ ] i would get a test every
single place they asked me to get yeah
yeah just to go
that's the world we live in well great
job dave thanks for doing all this for
people hope
maybe one day the government will follow
in your footsteps
you know hopefully that's the only way
they're gonna solve it or just open it
one of the other yeah
well maybe we'll run into you in miami
when you move operations there my man
all right
talk to you guys later see ya bye
we helped some people today we helped
some people i think
by help i think we paid for another
night on his yacht
i appreciate them all i love barstool
i've always [ __ ] with barstool yeah
they're cool people
caleb presley uh hooked this up and uh
he's he's one of the funniest guys there
he he does some like just
parodies of like nfl sunday
conversations and there's a funny kid
there's this kind of little sasquatch on
twitter
that works for them he's kind of funny
he's funny on twitter
big cat's like the most talented like if
you were to go out in his home
yeah super talented yeah yeah i just
heard of him but yeah
monster and the anus guys a new untold
story
uh it's uh kb and nick turani they're
they can improv
whatever happened to the show uh call
call her daddy
call us daddy that's still number one
they they the girls split up
sophia the other one is she's off doing
her own podcast that
scooter braun is behind people think and
then uh
uh alex cooper is still killing it with
caller daddy yeah she was great i had
them on firing the kid it was me and
santino
we didn't know who they were they didn't
know who we were so it was awkward right
she they her podcast like kept barstool
from laying off anybody over the
pandemic because they make so much money
on merch that's why when they like
had the deal where they were gonna split
because they wanted more money barstool
was like okay once this contract is up
you can have the ip
because if they didn't if they just like
held out and didn't do podcasts over the
pandemic they would have to lay up
they got they got paid and the other
girl did too i think it worked out
well for everybody and is the other girl
still with barcelona or she got up no
she got out she got out
yeah i heard her i heard her boyfriend
at the time was it bad it was a bad move
yeah bad move well worked out for
everyone shout out to dave portney yeah
good shout out to you man we're back at
this next week yeah we'll be back next
week thanks for having me
i appreciate it yeah i'm trying to think
oh i can let the people come next week
i feel bad i didn't realize well i fired
him
i fired i fired your pal and cat because
i told them you don't want to see their
faces
well they weren't hiring too much pay a
lot of money to not see their faces
let's be very honest you know my area
maybe we'll have a white culture corner
so tim feels safe just
feel more comfortable i appreciate it uh
all right man
hey i'm in san marcos texas january 29th
and 30th so texas get your mind right
all right and get your mask thanks
brendan and theo fighter and weight i
gotta go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible brendan's son hit me up he
said it's too loud in the club can you
pick me up
on a string
you